comme problème me to go to go back
[Musique]
mais
coderre c'est moi en corrèze il ya des
pommiers qui sont de pommiers qui sont
de très grande qualité il faut bien le
reconnaître et on fait des pommes pour
faire un dissident qui l'a pas non plus
la grande prétention mais que j'aime
bien
ce soir je ne suis pas le premier
ministre et vous n'êtes pas le président
de la république nous sommes deux
candidats à égalité
vous me permettrez donc de vous appeler
monsieur mitterrand vous avez tout à
fait raison mais c'est le premier
ministre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce choix nous célébrons la république
[Musique]
monsieur chirac vous êtes avec nous en
direct mais j'ai l'impression qu'il
n'entend pas monsieur chirac
qu'est ce qu'il lui arrive à la 2eme
faire chauffer l'appareil
[Musique]
l'irak ne représente pas aujourd'hui une
menace immédiate elle qu'elle justifie
une guerre immédiate
[Musique]
comment voulez vous que le travailleur
français qui habite à la boule temps où
je me promenais avec alain juppé est le
dernier tome 4 jours et qui travaille
avec sa part et qui ensemble gagne
environ 15000 francs et qu'ils voient
sur le palier à côté de loin j'ai l'air
entassés une famille avec un père de
famille trois ou quatre épouses et
emmanuelle devos et guiga 50000
prestations sociales sans naturellement
travailler
[Applaudissements]
là le bruit et l'odeur
et bien je le travaille en français sur
le palier bien fou
[Musique]
une histoire abracadabrantesque elles
font fuir quand je vais aussi me demande
même pas ce que je veux voir on m'a même
tout de suite une bouteille de bière
[Musique]